or more now on Russia's decision to lift
the ban on selling its s-300
anti-missile rocket system to ran now it
says that the system is purely for
defensive use but America and Israel
have expressed concern about the deal
national security analyst Irish aramesh
georgous live from Los Angeles lovely to
see there a rush first off why now why
do you think Russia's doing it now
that's a very good question and I've
heard and seen a range of explanations
for it the first the sort of most
dominant theory out there is that
sanctions are hurting and this is
Putin's way of pressuring the United
States and us is a European allies by
saying look you're going against us
we're going to arm the Iranians with
this this advanced air defense missile
system that Iran can use to safeguard as
nuclear facilities its military
facilities and so on and so forth this
is not a new deal that deal was signed
many years ago but over the past ten
years Russia refused to deliver the
s-300 missile system because of Israeli
pressure and American pressure but today
they announced that they were going to
actually deliver the system to the
Iranians and it has angered politicians
both in Washington and also in Jerusalem
I've also seen some explanations on a
more cynical side and that is that Putin
and Russia maybe are trying to sort of
derail the nuclear talks by creating a
yet another obstacle saying look this is
the outcome of the lisanna greement this
is the outcome of lifting around
sanctions and that would put pressure
here on the Prime President Obama and
his allies trying to get this deal
through with Iran and yet I understand
that President Putin or certainly Moscow
did have a conversation with Israel to
say that this deal would be going
through and yet Israel openly expressing
their concern yes apparently the Russian
Federation gave a heads up to the
Israelis that the Iranians were going to
receive these s-300 missiles now let's
be clear the s-300 air defense miss
system is not an impenetrable sort of
completely unbreakable system no the US
Air Force is far more superior to be
able to actually still penetrate any air
space even defended by s-300 or s400
missile series but it does elevate the
risk and the danger to our pilot
significantly it's no longer old iranian
defense systems but it's a pretty
complicated sophisticated russian system
that can engage multiple targets at the
same time now is it possible that when
the Russians gave sort of a notice to
the Israelis they also try to alleviate
their concerns by telling them how to
dismantle or how to evade these s-300
missiles that's something for us it will
probably not find out but it's
interesting that a Russia announced us
today in the midst of historic nuclear
talks and B they told the israelis
beforehand and Israel protested and just
off the back of this as well I rush
there were the talks going on in Berlin
over the crisis in Ukraine any any
connection there between timings
definitely I mean the Russians have a
limited a sort of arsenal in terms of
what they can use to pressure the West
and pressure the u.s. and us as allies
one is energy one is cutting you know
oil and gas supply sort of us there
already under tremendous sanctions so
that is really hurting them the Russian
ruble has dropped significantly the
Russian economy is hurting not by gonna
head and arming even in defensive
capabilities but by arming states that
are deemed to be problematic for the
West Russia is yet increasing its
pressure on the West saying look look
you sanction us you don't deal with us
in Ukraine we have our set of tools to
create problems for you in places like
Iran in the Mideast by supplying the
Assad regime it's an Assad and also in
other parts of the world let's not be
surprised in the next few weeks if we
see more Russian involvement in places
like Venezuela Cuba Bolivia and
elsewhere I share a mesh there in Los
Angeles thank you very much for your
time